[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
حيث الخبر
[تصفيق]
كريستيانو رونالدو
اوكرانيات تواجه ضربه قاسيه لروسيا
باستهداف موقع
الحالي
وسيكون معنا ايضا في العربيه 360 ويهبورك
مع الاصدقاء
[موسيقى]
بل هو النجم يبدا كريستيانو رونالدو فصلا
جديدا في مسيرته التاريخيه في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض امام الالاف في ملعب
منصور بارك تم تقديمه اللاعب الحاصل على
خمس كرات ذهبيه كافضل لاعب في العالم
وصاحب الارقام القياسيه التي لا تحصى يقول
رونالدو انه جاء ليجعل جماهير النصر سعداء
ويقول ايضا انه يريد ان يشارك في
المباريات في اقرب فرصه ممكنه في ما يؤكد
رئيس النصر ان صفقه رونالدو تؤكد ان
الدوريه السعوديه قادر على استقطاب
الاسماء الكبيره
[موسيقى]
معنا من الرياض الان مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي يرصد لنا المزيد من
التفاعلات والاصداء وردود الافعال بعد
تقديم نادي النصر لكريستيانو رونالدو على
اثر وصوله الى الرياض امس اذا اليك عبد
المحسن الكلمه لك وايضا لضيوفك من معجبي
ومحبين هذه النصر
الطاهر كانت ليله غير عاديه لعشاق النصر
وكذلك عشاق كريستيانو رونالدو الذين
توافدوا الى الملعب مبكرا لرؤيه رونالدو
في ظهور الاول على ملعب مرسول مبارك
ومرتديا قميص نادي
تضمن الحفل العديد من الفقرات حيث منذ
وصول كريستيانو رونالدو بدات همم فقرات
الحفل قبلها كان هنالك مؤتمر صحفي
لكريستيانو رونالدو برفقته رئيس نادي
النصر ومدرب نادي النصر تحدث كريستيانو عن
امور كثيره في من خلال هذا المؤتمر تحدث
عن انه تلقى العديد من العروض الاوروبيه
ولكنه اختار نادي النصر وقال باني
جئتم هنا للفوز وتحقيق البطولات وايضا
تحدث عن امر اخر مهم وهو مشاركته في
الرؤيا التطويليه لكره القدم في السعوديه
وهذا ما تحدث به رئيس نادي النصر بان هذه
الصفقه ليست رياضيه فحاسب بل تت قاع ذلك
الى امور اخرى في الحقيقه ردود الافعال
كبيره طاهر لدى مشجعين نادي النصر بعد هذا
همم هذا التقديم التاريخي لكريستيانو
رونالدو ربما ناخذ بعض اللقاءات لنرصد
ردود الافعال اليوم كيف شفت تقديم
كريستيانو رونالدو كريستيانو رونالدو كنت
تشاهد على الشاشه طوال السنوات الماضيه
اليوم شاهدته مرتدي قميص ناديك المفضل كيف
شفت هذا الموضوع همم صلاح الموضوع من
مفاجئ همم تشوف اللاعب اللي تشوفه دائما
في شاشات ويكون يعني هو قدوتك في كره
القدم قدامك همم كانت الجمهور حماسي همم
كلهم كانوا يطفون وكلهم كانوا معه همم
تدريب كان جميل جدا صراحه استمتعنا كلنا
يعني كيف شايف كريستيانو مسيره تبع نادي
النصر همم
اضافه ممتاز النادي النصر والدوري السعودي
راح تساهم بارتفاع الرتم الدوري
منافسه بالدوري منها ممكن مستوى الدوري
السعودي ارتفع بالترتيب العالمي اا وتصير
انديه الدوري السعودي افضل على شكل العام
بالفعل طاهر كما تحدث احد مشجعين الان
بان- اا كانت الهتافات عاليه لدرجه ان
مذيعي الحفل كانوا همم يهدئون الجمهور
قليلا نظرا للحماس الشديد والهتافات
لكريستيانو ايضا تقليد حركه الحركه
الشهيره لكريستيانو لدى
المشجعين ايضا همم ناخذ بعض اللقاءات همم
كيف كيف شفت اليوم
شعور جميل ومفرح ان احنا نراه في الدوري
السعودي وفي فريق معروف عالميا النصر وان
شاء الله الجايات اكثر ونشوف الدوري
السعودي اكثر من همم من افضل الدوريات في
اوروبا
هل سيحقق وسيجلب كريستيانو البطولات النصر
النصر جميعهم اليوم محتفلين وان شاء الله
البطولات قائده وتحقيق ان شاء الله الاعظم
والافضل مع الاعظم والعالمي مع العالم ان
شاء الله تحياتي اذا طاهر هذه هي الاجواء
خارج الملعب بعد انتهاء كافه فقرات الحفل
التي انتهت في تقديم لاعبين النصر وكذلك
الفريق الفني همم حصه تدريبيه للمره
الاولى همم امام الجماهير التي حضرها
الكثير من
مشجعي
اليك وهذه صور مباشره
بيننا نتابع في الحديث معك عن هذا الموضوع
ولو نتابع صوت طبيعي
[تصفيق]
كريستيانو رونالدو يشارك اذا في تدريبات
نادي النصر للمره الاولى بعد اتمام هذه
الصفقه ووصوله وتقديمه من قبل ناديه
الجديد وعبد المحسن الحربي اللي عم بغطي
الموضوع ما بتقدر اكيد تكون نموذج متجرد
من مشاعرك وعواطفك نصراوي كما عرفت وانك
حاولت كثيرا ان تاتي بالبطاقه ولكن لم
تستطع هل هذا ما حصل فعلا
بالفعل طاهر كان في المؤتمر الصحفي
كرستيانو رونالدو اا كانت ايضا كثير من
المشاعر بصفتي صحفي غير رياضي
حاولت ان اتجرد كثيرا من هذا المشاعر ولكن
الحدث تاريخي وعظيم طاهر اكبر من ان ااا
تكون متجرد الى درجه كبيره ولكن هذا هذا
القدوم لي الكل فرح به ليس اا مشجعين نادي
النصر فقط بل كل مشجعين الانديه الاخرى
الذين ايضا حضروا وتوافدوا الى ملعب
المباراه شهد الكثير من مشجعين همم الهلال
الاهلي الاتحاد
لرؤيه نجمهم الاول لكرستيانو رونالدو
الذين كانوا يتابعونه عبر الشاشات طوال
اكثر من 15 سنه ولكنه الان يتواجد في دوري
روشن السعودي
همم مباشره امامهم ف- هذه لحظه تاريخيه
طاهر كل تاكيد الجميع
محاوله التجرد ولكن الذي صورتي نشاهدها
ايضا تاريخيه لتدريبات النصر همم نتفهم
ذلك بطبيعه الحال ولكن على الاقل تخرج لنا
بالقميص الاصفر المره القادمه شكرا جزيلا
لك عبد المحسن الحربي مراسل العربيه من
الرياض تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
بحث رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
هاتفيه مع الرئيس الاوكراني
الروسيه الاخيره بالمسيرات ضد اوكرانيا
دعم اكياس على المدى الطويل
من جهته اكد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون على مواصله دعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
روسيا بشكل اكثر او اكبر من اي وقت مضى
على حد تعبيره
احتياجات اوكرانيا في مواجهه العدوان
الروسي مع حلول فصل الشتاء الاوكرانيون
بحاجه لدعمنا اكثر من اي وقت مضى سنتحدث
ايضا عن عضويه السويد في الناتو التي
يتمنى ان اراها تحدث في اقرب وقت ممكن
بالاضافه الى عضويه فنلندا
تحدثنا بالامس في العربيه 360 عن حرب
المسيرات او الحرب التي تقترب من حدود
روسيا سلاح يبرز يوما بعد يوم ويثبت توجه
المتزايدا لاستخدامه من طرفي النزاع
الرئيس الاوكراني كشف معلومات عن خطط
روسيه لحمله طويله تشنها المسيرات هدفها
استنزاف اوكرانيا وقال انه تلقى تقارير
استخباراتيه تشير الى ان موسكو ستشن
الهجمات باستخدام طائرات شاهد ايرانيه
الصنع ويبدو ان غارات مسيرات الروسيه على
اوكرانيازدات بشكل ملحوظ اذ شنت موسكو
هجمات على المدن على محطات الطاقه في جميع
انحاء البلاد خاصه خلال الليالي الثلاثه
الماضيه لكنها سيلنسكي اكد على وجوب ضمان
ان يفشل من اسمائهم الارهابيين بتحقيق
اهداففهم خصوصا بعد ما تصدق في دفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه ودمرت عشرات الطائرات
الروسيه ايرانيه الصبح
من معايا
باستخدام طائرات شاهد المسيره ومن المحتمل
ان يكون الهدف من وراء ذلك استنزاف شعبنا
وانظمه الدفاع عن الجويه وقطاع الطاقه
لدينا نحن نتصرف ونفعل كل ما بوسعنا
لافشالهم من تحقيق اهدافهم
حديثي ياتي بعدما نفذت اوكرانيا ضربه قالت
انها قتلت مئات الجنود الروس في منطقه دوم
بس وفي اعتراف نادر للغايه قالت روسيا ان
الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل 63
لم يتم التحقق منهما لكن
المعلق الموالي لروسيا قال ان المئات
قتلوا وجرحوا رغم ان العدد الدقيقه غير
معروف بسبب العدد الكبير الذي لا يزال
مفقودا وقال ان المبنى نفسه دمر بالكامل
تقريبا واضاف على تليجرام ان الضحايا
كانوا في الاساس من القوات التي تم
التعبئتها اي من المجندين الجدد وليس من
اولئك الذين اختاروا القتال وقال ايضا ان
الذخيره كانت مخزنه في المبنى نفسه الذي
كان فيه الجنود ما زاد ضرر
عسكري
عندما احتلوا اجزاء كبيره عام 2014
تع- 17
ورغم موقفه المتشدد ضد اكياف الا انه
ينتقد بانتظام القياده العسكريه الروسيه
وتكتيكاتها لم يكن امام موسكو خيار سوى
الاعتراف بالخسائر في صفوف جنودها ولو ان
العدد يختلف كليا عما طرحه موالها ينتقد
العديد من المشرعين الروس القياده
العسكريه ومنهم سرجيني رونالدو الرئيس
السابق لمجلس الشيوخ الروسي الذي قال انه
من الواضح انه لا المخابرات ولا الدفاع
الجوي يعملان بشكل صحيح لقد كان هجوما
مميتا او قاع اكبر عدد من القتل اعترفت به
موسكو في حادثه واحده منذ بدء الحرب يقول
مدون عسكري
[موسيقى]
ومع مرور الايام الثقيله للحرب تكتسب
القوات الاوكرانيه مهارات جديده وكبيره في
الدفاع ضد الطائرات الروسيه بدون طيار
اسقطت كيف جميع الطائرات بدون طيار البالغ
عددها 39 طائره امس وافقه ما افدت به
صحيفه نيويورك
منذ بدايه العام وعدد الطائرات بدون تيار
الايرانيه التي اسقطت فوق اوكرانيا تجاوز
بالفعل 80 طائره اطلقت روسيا امس سربا
كبيرا من الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه على
اهداف المدنيه داخل اوكرانيا قال سلاح
الجو الاوكراني ان ايا من انه لم يمر
وافقت جميعها ببنادق مضاده للطائرات
وصواريخ ارض جو وطائرات حربيه عشرون طائره
منها اسقطت فوق كياف وحدها وبحسب الصحيفه
الامريكيه فانه يكون احد اسباب نجاح ثياب
ضد حمله الطائرات المسيره الروسيه قرار
واشنطن في اوائل نوفمبر الماضي تزويد
اوكرانيا بنظام صاروخي ارض جو متقدم يعرف
باسم من ساندز تحدثنا كثيرا عن ساند في
360 ونذكر بانه يشمل رادارا واجهزه
استشعار وقذفات ومركز قياده متنقلا ووفقا
لمركز الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه وامن
المعلومات وهو وكاله حكوميه اوكرانيه لعب
نظام الصواريخ الامريكي دورا في صد هجوم
امس وقال المركز على تويتر رغم تعلمنا
تشغيلها قبل اسابيع قليله فقط استخدمها
جيشنا تقريبا كان المدفعيه واعاده تحميلها
باسرع ما يمكن الاستخدام الناجح للغايه
لهذه الاسلحه يظهر ان جنودنا يتعلمون
بسرعه لكن مسكت تخطط لشيء اكبر من
المسيرات في حرب يبدو انها او ان نهايتها
ستطول اذ قال الفريق السابق قائد الطيران
بعيد المدى في القوات الجويه والفضائيه
الروسيه ان الطائرات الحامله للصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه ست تشارك في منطقه العمليات
العسكريه الخاصه في 20 23 الفريق كوبيلاس
انه سيتم تركيزه خلال تدريب الطيارين خلال
العام الحالي على تحسين مهارات استخدام
الاسلحه وانظمه القياده والتوجيه الاليه
مشيرا الى ان الط احنا الشباب المتدربين
بشكل جيد تلقوا الخبره القتاليه للمره
الاولى تصريح يثير تساؤل كبيرا هل تنفدت
موسكو سلاح جوها التقليديه لتلجا للقاذفات
بعيده المدى
[موسيقى]
معنى من مسكم مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه اهلا بكما
وابدا معك عبد الجواد كيف ترد موسكو من
خلال
القنوات الرسميه او غير الرسميه التي تمرر
بها بعض الرسائل على موضوع استنزاف حتى
قدره موسكو بالطائره المسيره التي تاتي
بها من ايران ما المعلن وغير المعلن في
هذا الموضوع
طاهر مساء الخير لك ولي حذيفه ثلاث نقاط
بارزه طبعا يمكن مشاهدتها اليوم في
القراءه السياسيه لما حدث في دينه في
دينيتك ومقتل واصابه العشرات من الجنود
الروسي في ذلك المعسكر المؤقت لتوزيع من
تم تعبئتهم في الاونه الاخيره طبعا النقطه
الاولى وهي تكمن في ان الاول من يناير من
هذا العام دخل قرار او يعني مرسوم رفع عدد
القوات الروسيه بشكل عام في البلاد الى
مليونين و40 الف جندي حيز التنفيذ ايضا
الشيء الثاني والنقطه الهامه هي دخول
الطائرات الاستراتيجيه العمليات العسكريه
للعمليه الخاصه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وهذا طبعا قد يلعب دورا محوريه في الفتره
القادمه حسب رؤيه القراءه العسكريه
والمحللين العسكريين في البلاد لكن طبعا
الكثير من القراءات راحت تتحدث عن ان رده
فعل موسكو لما حدث هناك نلاحظها اليوم
على الارض طبعا بيان وزاره الدفاع الروسي
اليوم يتحدث عن تحييد واصابه اكثر من 400
شخصا في العديد من المناطق في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ايضا يتحدث عن تصفيه اكثر من
مئه وثلاثين مرتزقا اجنبيا كما تسميهم
موسكو كانوا يعملون لصالح القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى ضرب منصات
الصواريخ التي طبعا انطلقت منها صواريخ
هايمارسك وبعض الراجمات التشيكيه طبعا
لذلك القراءه السياسيه لما يحدث الان في
في في يعني في مناطق العمليات في الاراضيه
الاوكرانيه هي تصعيد بشكل كبير موسكو
اصبحت تتحدث بشكل رسمي عن كافه المعطيات
الخسائر والمناطق التي يتم السيطره عليها
واعداد الجنود بشكل واضح كما ذكرت دفاع
موسكو اليوم طاهر
كما ما تبقى معنا حذيفه بخصوص التصدي
للطائرات المسيره فوق ثياب وغير اكياف
كذلك تسجل الاخبار نجاحا كبيرا لكياد في
هذا المجال ما اخر المعلومات حول الانظمه
الجديده التي تم امداد كيف بها لنجاحها في
ذلك
وعلامه راهم اوكرانيا الان في استمرار
المواجهه
تحياتي طاهر لك ولزمين عبد الجواد في
الحقيقه من خطاب الرئيس زيننسكي اليوم
يمكن ان يفهم عن موقع همم انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الاساسيه التي تعتمد عليها كيف في
صدرها جماعه الجويه شكران الرئيس الامريكي
واثنى على ثلاثه ادويه في الجيش الاوكراني
لواءته
والذي يقاتل في الشرق الاوكراني وكذلك همم
وايضا شكر لواء البحريه الذي يقاتل في في
الجبهه الجنوب شرق البلاد وهذا همم
لتصديهم لجميع الضربات الصاروخيه
والطائرات المسيره على في همم اغلب التي
تستهدف الاراضي القرانيه
على هذه الثلاثه ومواقع مركز على صدرها
هجمات التي تاتي من الاراضي الروسيه او من
الاراضي المسيطر عليها من قبل الاتحاد
الروسي داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه طبعا
اليوم ايضا كان هنالك 8 مسيرات تم اطلاقها
وتم اسقاطها جميعا وكذلك تنفذت 18 ضربه
جويه من قبل الاتحاد الروسي ايضا احببت
جميع هذه الضربات بانظمه الدفاع الجوي
والتي تعتمد على باتريوت وناس
والانظمه الجديده التي حصلت عليها من
الحلفا الناتو وايضا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طبعا اليوم ايضا بيان هيئه
الاركان تحدث عن ضربات نفذتها دفاع
الاوكرانيا سلاح الجو الاوكراني عفوا وقال
انه دمر مراكز مناطق تمركز للمعدات
والاليات والجنود النص في اربعه مواقع
ولكنه خاصه بالذكر بسبوسه وهي في منطقه
خرسان وقال انه استهدف هذا الموقع وتم
تحديد 500 جندي يعني هو قال انه قتل
الاغلبيه وهنالك عدد كبير من الجرح والرقم
يقدر ب 500 فرد من افراد القوات المسلحه
الروسيه في منطقه اخر سون ايضا ايضا همم
افادت همم الاداره الجنوبيه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بتق في احدى الجزر
الصغيره من الضفه اليسرى الى الضفه اليمنى
وقالت انها استطاعت ان ترفع العلم ولكن لم
يتم الاعلان عن كامله السيطره وحتى ان
نتالي اجو منطق الرسمي باسم القياده
الجنوبيه قالت انه يجب ان لا يتم تداول
المعلومات من قبل المواطنين لانها تضر
بالعمليه العسكريه الجاريه الان في تلك
المنطقه ايضا الجديده اليوم في لوغاز وهو
الطريق الاستراتيجي صفاته والذي تقاتل
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه من اجله منذ
عده ايام اليوم هو تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه وهذه ضربه كبيره لجيش الاتحاد
الروسي في تلك المنطقه هذا الطريق هو طريق
الاستراتيجي تحصل القوات المقاتله في كريم
على الامدادات والان هي تضطر الى ان تاخذ
طرق بديله وعائره وتاخذ وقت اطول وصعبه
لاصاله الامدادات لجبهه التي فيها في تلك
المنطقه شكرا لك حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه
في العربيه 360 ايضا الجمهوريون المنقسمون
يستعيدون السيطره على مجلس النواب ويجهزون
لبيض تحقيقات تبدا من افغانستان ولا تنتهي
بازمه الحدود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال مسؤول في مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو انه
ملتزم للحفاظ على الوضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى وذلك بعد اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
باحات الاقصى وسط حراسه المشدده في خطوه
دانتها رئاسه الفلسطينيه وبلدان عربيه
الخارجيه السعوديه اعرضت عن ادانه المملكه
للممارسات الاستفزازيه للمسؤول الاسرائيلي
وعبارات الوزاره في بيان عن اسفي المملكه
لما تقوم به اسرائيل من ممارسات تقود جهود
السلام الدوليه وتتعارض مع المبادئ
والاعراف الدوليه في احترام المقدسات
الدينيه كما اعربت مصر والاردن والامارات
والكويت وقطر وجامعه الدول العربيه عن
ادانت اقتحام المسؤول الاسرائيلي باحات
المسجد الاقصى
[موسيقى]
على واقع الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بين كبير مساحات المسجد
الاقصى سرعه اسرائيل الى رفع حاله التاهب
خاصه على حدود قطاع غزه خشيه من اطلاق
صواريخ وخوفا من عدم اختصار ردود الفعل
الشعبي والرسميه الفلسطينيه على بيانات
التمديد والاستنكار الشعب الفلسطيني لن
يرضى بتمرير هذه الجرائم اليوميه من
اقتحامات للاقصى وكانت الاقتحامات تتم على
يد المستوطنين الان تتم اعياد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
ان يضع قواعد جديده للعبه في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وانا اقول انه سيتحمل
المسؤوليه عن نتائج هذه اللعبه لان اللاعب
بالمسجد الاقصى المبارك هو بالعدل عبر
النار بالتجربه عام 67 وحتى اللحظه وكان
الوزير المتطرف بين كبير لجا الى نوع من
الخدعه حيث اشعه ان اقتحامه الاقصى تاجل
بعد تحفظ نتنياهو لكن الرجلين كانت اتفق
على الاقتحام مسبقا
تم مده 13 دقيقه فقط بشكل غير معلن اما
نتياه فتجاهل الحديث عن الاقتحام في جلسه
الحكومه وفضلت تحدث عن ايران
الاتفاق النووي الخطير شطب عن طاوله البحث
بعد الاحداث الاخيره في ايران اعتقد بان
هذه الامكانيه ما زالت قائمه ولم تنتهي
في حكومه انا عضو فيها لن تكون هناك تفرقه
عنصريه اليهود سيصعدون لجبل الهيكل ونوضح
لحماس اننا لن نتراجع وفي العوده الى
الاقتحام فان بين كبير سبق وانت تسبب
بالحرب الاخيره على قطاع غزه بعد
اقتحاماته متكرره لساحات الاقصى وحي الشيخ
جراح لكن الاقتحام الحالي يبدو مغيرا بعد
ان اصبح في موقع صنع قرار يعرف بن كبير في
اسرائيل بانه مشعله حرائق تقليديه وقد وضع
حاليا بالقرب من برميل من البارود
واقتحامه للمسجد الاقصى سيصب الزيت على
نار المواجهه مع الفلسطينيين الذين يقولون
بان التطرف لم يعد تصريحات او شعارات وان
ممارسه على الارض زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الشرقيه المحتله
[موسيقى]
ثقه الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي
في انتخاب رئيسا له في دوره تصويت الاولى
ضمن الجوله الافتتاحيه من التصويت وذلك
للمره الاولى منذ 100 عام ولم يتمكن
المرشح الاقوى النائب عن ولايه كاليفورنيا
كان المكارسي من نيللي دعم الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الديمقراطيون بعد الانتخابات النصفيه في
نوفمبر اذا مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الجمهوريون وحصل ماكرتي على 200 وثلاثه
اصوات مقابل 2002 10 لزعيم الاقليه
الديمقراطيه هذا ولجا النواب الامريكيون
الى جوله ثانيه من التصويت
هذا الاخفاق لا يخفي حقيقه سيطره
الجمهوريين اليوم رسميا على مجلس النواب
لينهو بذلك رسميا افضل ايام بيضا في الحكم
الرئيس والديمقراطي الذي لم يجد اي صعوبه
في تمرير اجنده منذ تنصيبه قبل عامين
سيبدا من اليوم بالاضطرار الى التعامل مع
الواقع الجديد الصعب تقول فورم بوليسيه
انه بغض النظر عن هويه رئيس مجلس النواب
الجديد الا ان الامر اشبه بشوكه في خاصرت
بيضا
الاولويه الان او البندق الاولويه القصوى
لدى الجمهوريين هو التحقيق في انسحاب
القوات الامريكيه الفضيه من افران والفشل
في اجلاء المدنيين متعددين الجنسيات من
كابول مثلا النائب الجمهوري مايكل صادق
تقريرا قاسيا حول هذا الانسحاب حمل فيه
بايدا مسؤوليات الفشل في تنفيذ اتفاق
الانسحاب الذي تم في عهد الامر الاكثر
اهميه ان مايكل هو المرشح الاوفر حظا
لرئاسه لج الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
اي انه سيسعى لتضييق الخناق على بايرن
تقول لافورين بوليسي ايضا ان مسؤولي اداره
بيدن الذين افلتوا من الاستجواب حول
الانسحاب خلال سيطره الديمقراطيين على
الكونجرس سيخضعون الان لجلسات استماع
طويله
[موسيقى]
العطره الثانيه التي سيضعها الجمهوريون في
طريق هي كيفيه تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا
مثلا السنه الجمهوريه عن ولايه اوهايو
جديفانس قال بعباره صريحه انه لا يهتم حقا
بما يحدث لاوكرانيا ثم هناك مشكله اخرى
لم يتوقفوا عند هذا الحد بل ان هناك نيه
للوصول لما هو ابعد فمثلا يستهدفون الان
النيل من مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
كريستوفري الذي يقود تحقيقا بشان وثائق
ترامب سريه بدا الحديث من اندي بيجز
النائب عن اريزونا الذي طالب في وقفه
تمويل الاجهزه الفاسده على حد وصفه ومنها
الاف بي اي
الناس
[تصفيق]
الامنيسا
في المكتب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنى من واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي مراسله
العربيه
ما سبب هذا الاخفاق وماذا نتوقع الان
مساء الخير طاهر وكل عام وانت بخير طبعا
كان المفروض ان ينتصر الجمهوريون او
يحتفلون بهذا الانتصار كما تعرف في اول
يوم في العام الجديد لكن يبدو بان حفنه
اذا اردت 5 او 6 نواب يعتبرون او يصنفون
بانهم نواب متشددين يمنيين مواليين للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب هم الذين عطلوا
انتخاب قبل مقاسي يعني هذا الرجل الذي كان
يطمح الى هذا المنصب منذ كنا نتحدث عن
الانتخابات النصفيه بانه هو الوريث الجديد
اللي هذا لرئاسه المجلس
لكنه يظهر ايضا ماذا قدرت وصلابه هذه
المراه التي استطاعت ان ربما توحد حسبها
ليس فقط بالخروج بمشاريع لتصويت عليها
وتقديمها للرئيس لكن ايضا في موضوع بسيط
جدا مثل انتخاب هذا همم الانتخاب لهذا
المنصب كما تعرف هؤلاء الاشخاص ليس لديه
البديل وهذه هي الماضي لامام الجمهوريين
انقسام حاد الاغلبيه منهم يريدون بالفعل
ان يكون كيف المقاطع الذي يعتبر يعني يمين
وسط اذا اردت رغم انه ذهب الى مرا لارج
وحصل على مباركه من الرئيس ترامب في فتره
من الفترات الا ان هذه المجموعه الصغيره
تختطف الحزب الجمهوري وتمنع للمره الاولى
في تاريخ الولايات المتحده منذ 100 عام
كما ذكر 1923 كانت هناك جوله اعاده وسنرى
بالفعل اذا كان حتى في جوله الاعاده سيكون
هناك اقناع عليها هؤلاء النواب بالتصويت
لكيفن مقاسي والا عليه ان يتنحى وان يكون
هناك بديل اخر للحزب الجمهوري ليكون رئيسا
المجلس
همم ايضا اجواء همم هذه الجلسه المستمره
همم تحت قبه الكونجرس الامريكيه بعد
الاخفاق في الدوره الاولى باختيار همم
الرئيس همم جمهوري لمجلس النواب همم ناديه
انتقل الى الشرق الاخر المتعلق طبعا ولكن
الاعم بخصوص المشهد السياسي الذي يدخل
بيدن امام كونجرس منقسم الى اي مدى سيتم
تكبيله همم من قبل الجمهوريين يبدو
الاتهامات لانه على مصرعيها في قضايا
حساسه جدا مثل المواضيع ترامب اوكرانيا
والاف بي اي حتى
البدايه غير موفقه للجمهوريين في عدم
قدرتهم على اختيار رئيس المجلس فهذا سيعطل
الاجنده نوعا ما بالنسبه لللجان التي
ستدعي كما ذكرت همم رؤساء سواء كان الاف
بي اي او حتى ربما وزير الخارجيه للحديث
وزير الدفاع للحديث عن الخروج الفوضى ومن
افغانستان او هنتر وعلاقته بالشركات
الصينيه او حتى
وغيرهم لكن اعتقد بانه سيكون هناك انشغال
داخلي في معارك يعني ما رايناه اليوم
وصوره مصغره لما سيحدث خلال عامين قادمين
وهذا ما حدث على فكره مع رئيسين لمجلس
النواب جمهور يعني مثل بول راين طبعا همم
جون بيرر الذين اضطراء الى ترك هذا المنصب
بسبب الخلاف والانقسام داخل الحزب
الجمهوري اذا ربما ال- همم الاخبار
اليوميه ساره بالنسبه للبيت الابيض ولا
الديمقراطيين لانه ما استطاعوا ان ينتخبوا
اليوم همم كرئيس الاقليه في لسه النواب
همم بدون اي مشاكل يعني كان هناك كانه
احتفال كان العكس هو الصحيح اليوم لكن
اعتقد بانه هذه اللجان اكيد ستستدعي همم
اركان الاداره لكن اعتقد بانه ما حدث
اليوم ربما سيعطل من الاجنده وخصوصا بانها
هؤلاء الاشخاص يفرضون على من سيكون رئيس
المجلس هو كان كيفن مقاسي اذا نجح في
النهايه او السيبس خليه او غيره من ان
الجمهوريين قد يفرضون عليهم ايضا اجنده
متطرفه سيعطلون من بعض المشاريع لانهم
بالفعل همم ايدولوجيين يعني صعب ان يتم
المساومه معهم وهذه ازمه ومشكله ومعدله
الحزب الجمهوريه بعد تسلم الرئيس دونالد
ترامب لقيادته والذي اصبح الراب الحزب رغم
يعني الجروح التي عانى منها مؤخرا جروح
سياسيه
الايدي فيما يتعلق بتكبير او بعمل ما
يريدون بما ان الديمق لا يظل انه يسيطرون
على مجلس الشيوخ تحت قبه الكونجرس ولو
سيطر جمهوريون على مجلس النواب ناديه
البلبيسي مراسله العربيه من واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات ولنا لقاءات
اخرى ان شاء الله تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
في حوار مع صحيفه الفرنسيه اكد الباحث في
الشؤون الايرانيه ان النظام الايراني
بامكانه ان يزيد من قمع الاحتجاجات مشيرا
في الوقت ذاته الى ان الثوره في ايران
تجذب كل من يرفض عزله بلاده نتابع ايضا مع
الخبر العازل ورد عن الاعلام الايراني
الرسمي قبل قليل عن مقتل عنصر في الحرس
الثوري باطلاق نار في العاصمه الايرانيه
طهران اذا اعلام ايراني رسمي يتحدث عن
مقتل لعنصر في الحرس الثوري باطلاق نار في
طهران وقد تعرض لاطلاق النار هذا امام
منزله
رغم الضغوط والانتقادات الدوليه للنظام
الايراني بسبب قمعه الاحتجاجات المندلعه
منذ مقتل مهس امني تدل مؤشرات على قدره
السلطه الايرانيه على رفع وتيره القمع ضد
المتظاهرين خلال الفتره المقبله النظام
الايراني بامكانه ان يزيد من قمع
الاحتجاجات الكلام هنا للباحث في الشؤون
الايرانيه يا غشاغ في مقابله مع صحيفه
الفرنسيه
صاحبه كتاب الشيطان الاكبر الشهوه الامام
وضاع مقارنه بين وضع ايران اي مشا سنه قبل
سقوطه اي عام
1978 وحال النظام الايراني حاليا وخلص الى
ان الملل في ايران يمثلون طبقه متماسكه
الى حد ما مضيفا ان الخلافات الداخليه بما
في ذلك في صفوف الحرس الثوري تظهر ان
القمع الشرسه لم يعد بالاجماع لكنه قد
يتطور اكثر
الباحث ذاته يعتبر ما سماها بالثوره في
ايران تجذب كل اولئك الذين يرون ان فساد
قادتهم وعدم كفاءتهم تسبب بالركود والعزله
الدوليه مضيفا ان الامر سيتطلب المزيد
لتغيير النظام لكن في المقابل يمكن ان
يزيد من تكثيف القمع يا غشاغ اضاف ايضا ان
اداء الامريكيين يعزز اكثر النظام
الايراني ويدفعه الى طلب الحمايه الروسيه
خاصه في المجال العسكري ما يجعل المحتجين
يستنكرون هذه التدخلات بالنظر الى التكلفه
الباهظه التي تترتب عنها وفقا الباحث نفسه
بلال الوجداني العربيه
في العربيه 360 ايضا البرازيل تودع صانعه
مجدها بيليه الى اعلى مقبره في البلاد في
موكب حفل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وردود الافعال لازالت
تتوالى على اقتحام اثمار بن غفير المسجد
الاقصى البيت الابيض يقول ان امريكا تؤيد
بحزم الحفاظ على الوضع الراهن للمواقع
المقدسه في القدس
عرض الاتحاد الاوروبي على الصين تزويدها
بلقاحات مجانيه
بعد تخفيف التكين سياستها صفر واوضح متحدث
باسم المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان الصين لم ترد
بعد على العرض الاوروبي هذا ولم يحدد
المتحدث كميه اللقاحات التي عرضها الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الصين او الشركات المصنعه
ونتابع واياكم من انطلاق الجائحه من الصين
واليها تعود عوده تهدد من جديد العالم
بتفشل وبائيا جديد ومتحورات مستجده قدتربق
العالم وتعيد الى اذهانه كابوس الاغلاقات
تشهد الصين زياده كبيره في اعداد الاصابات
بعدما رفعت الشهر الماضي فجاه ومن دون
استعدادات تذكر قيودا صارما للحد من تفشي
كوففت امر احدث ضغطا كبيرا على المستشفيات
ومحارق الجثث زياده وصلت الى نسب مرتفعه
جدا اذا افادت وزاره الصحه الكوريه
الجنوبيه بان واحدا من كل خمسه وافدين من
الصين الى كوريا الجنوبيه مصاب بفيروس
كورونا المستجد ما دفع الحكومه الكوريه
لفرد اجراء اختبار بي سي ار على الوافدين
من الصين خلال اليوم الاول من وصولهم بعد
ما تاكد امس اصابه واحدا 61 وافدا عبر
مطار انشيون الدولي بالفا
اليوم
[موسيقى]
52 واحدا بمن فيهم طاقم خطوط الطيران
خاضعه منهم 300 وتسعه اجانب لبي سي ار فور
وصولهم وتبين ان واحدا 61 شخصا ايمن نسبته
19.7 مصاب بفيروس كورونا
ويلزم الوافدون من الصين بمنفيهم
المواطنين الكوريون والاجانب المقيمون
لمده اكثر من 90 يوما باستثناء المقيمين
الاجانب لمده اقل من ذلك بالخضوع لاختبار
بي سي ار في غضون يوم واحد من دخول
لكنها سول ليست الوحيده التي بدات بفرض
قيود على القادمين من الصين جوا فالولايات
المتحده واعتبارا من الخامس من يناير
سيتعين على جميع المسافرين جو ممن تبلغ
اعمارهم عامين فاكثر تقديم نتيجه سلبيه
لفحص اجري قبل يومين على الاقل من مغادره
الصين او هونج كونج او ماكاو كذلك حدث
بريطانيا وفرنسا حد والولايات المتحده بل
حظه باريس جميع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاخرى البالغ عددها 26 دوله على فحص
المسافرين الصينيين لرصد الاصابات بيكو ضد
استراليا وكندا والهند للركب اليابان
وتايوان وماليزيا بدورها اتخذت الخطوات
نفسها واعلن طوكيو ان الحكومه ستحد من
الطلبات المقدمه من شركات الطيران لزياده
الرحلات الى الصين ومن العالم العربي
اتخذت كل من المغرب وقطر اجراءات الممثله
امام القادمين من الصين
تؤدي الحكومه واجبها في حمايه الفرنسيين
من خلال طلب الاختبارات المسافرون من
الصين الى فرنسا يتعاهدون بقبول اجراء
الاختبار عند وصولهم ما يساعدنا في الحصول
على بيانات حول تطور الفيروس والتاكد من
وجوده نفعل ذلك مع احتراما كامل لقواعد
منظمه الصحه العالميه وصنوان وصل
وامامه
غير المقبوله ضد الوافدين من اراضيها بل
وهددت باتخاذ اجراءات مضاده مبنيه على
مبدا المعامله بالمثل الخارجيه الصينيه
وقالت ان بعض البلدان فرضت قيودا على دخول
المسافرين تستهدف الصينيين فقط مشيره الى
ان ذلك يفتقر على اساس او الى اساس علمي
وتعد بعض الممارسات غير مقبوله كما
اعتبارات
[موسيقى]
كويتي مستعدون للتواصل مع العالم للتغلب
على رائحه كورونا لكننا نعتقد ان قيود
الدخول التي فرضتها بعض الدول على الصين
تفتقر الى الاساس العلمي وبعض الممارسات
في غير المقبوله الصين تعارض بشده محاولات
التلاعب باجراءات الوقايه من الوباء
ومكافحته لاغراض سياسيه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
المناسبه وفقا لمبدا المعامله بالمثل
في مسهل العام الجديد يحذر كبار اطباء
هيئه الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه في بريطانيا
من ان الضغط الحالي على الخدمات الصحيه قد
يؤدي الى انهيارها مع تزايد مرضى
المستشفيات بسبب الامراض الموسميه عدد من
المستشفيات نصح الناس بعد زياره اقسام
الطوارئ بعدم زياره اقسام الطوارئ الا في
الحاله القصوى
ارتفاع الحالات المرضيه المرتبطه بفصل
الشتاء يزيد من ازمه الخدمات الصحيه في
المستشفيات ما قد يفاقم من توفير الرعايه
الصحيه ويعرض حياه الناس لخطر اسوا ما كان
عليه في ذروه جائه كورونا تحذير اطلقه
المسؤولون في قطاع الصحه
المقبل
على الصحه العامه
على خلفيه هذا التحذيري ومخوف من ان تزيد
عوده التلاميذ الى المدارس الضغط على
النظام الصحي اصدرت وكاله الامن الصحي في
بريطانيا نصائح بابقاء من يعاني من حمى في
المنزل لتجنب اصابه الاخرين وارتداء
كمامات في حال الاضطرار الى الخروج وتجنب
خدمات الصحه الا في الظروف القصوى بسبب
التزايد اعداد مرضى المستشفيات
بالانفلونزا وكرونا والحمى القرمزيه التي
وصلت الى ما يقارب 10,000 مريض هذا الى
جانب اوقات الانتظار الطويله التي قد تؤدي
الى وفاه خمس مئه شخص في الاسبوع بسبب
التاخير في رعايه الطوارئ بحسب الكليه
الملكيه للطب الطوارئ
الحجر الشديد عندما تنظر الى ارقام
الوفيات الزائده واذا عقدنا مقارنه دوليه
سنجد ان العديد من الانظمه الصحيه بعد
خروجها من جائ كورنا تشهد معدلات وفايات
اعلى من ما تتوقعه تقليديا وهذا هو الحال
في المانيا وايطاليا واسبانيا
تحذير مسؤولي الصحه يعكس الضغط الكبيره في
الخطوط الاماميه لقطاع الصحه قبل جائع
كورونا والذي يعاني من نقص في كوادره
وقائمه انتظار وصلت لاول مره الى سبعه
ملايين مريض
لم يسبق لهيئه الخدمات الصحيه في بريطانيا
ان عاشت ازمه مماثله لمده ثانيه القرن
الماضي بالرغم من ضخم ملياراته في قطاع
الصحه ولا يبدو حل مشاكله في المستقبل
المنظور لملئ الوظائف الشاغره وتقليس
قوائم الانتظار الطويله مصطفى زاروه
العربيه
بلا صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 وهي من
دوري كره القدم الامريكيه للحظه سقوط
اللاعب في فريق بافلوبلز دمار هاملن قبل
اصابته بازمه قلبيه وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه قالت انها هاملا صاحب رقم ثلاثه
الذي يظهر امامكم الان قد اصيب في صدره
بذراع احد لاعبي الفريق المنافس ليقف بعد
الاصابه على قدمه لمده ثلاث ثواني قبل ان
ينهار على ارضيه الملعب واكدت اداره دوري
كره القدم الامريكيه ان اللاعب في حاله
حرجه ويخضع للعلاج في المركز الطبي لجامعه
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 هو من الامير
هاري نجل الملك تشارلز الثالث حول توتر
علاقته مع العائله الملكه يقول الامير
هاري ان العائله لم تظهر له اي رغبه في
المصالحه معه بعد ان ساءت علاقته وعلاقه
زوجته مجان ماركل مع العائله الملكيه
ويضيف انه يريد استعاده علاقته بوالده
وشقيقه لكنهما لا يريدون او لا يريدان
المصالحه معه مشيرا الى انه يريد ان يعيش
في عائله لا في مؤسسه ملكيه
فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360 هو لعمليه
انقاذ تحبس الانفاس في ولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه حيث سقطت سياره تسلا من فوق
منحدر جبلي في الولايه وكانت السياره تقل
اربعه اشخاص رغم انقلاب السياره الا انه
لم يتعرض راكبها لاذى وقامت خدمات طوارئ
لانقاذهم عبر مروحيه
هكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام العربيه 360
لكن اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع مستمره مع صهيب
سرايا الان وملفات اخبار الساعه مساء
الخير صهيب مساء الخير يا طاهر وطبعا خبر
الساعه يبقى الاحتفال والتقديم الاسطوري
للنجم كريستيانو رونالدو في الرياض بعد
انضمامه رسميا اذا الى نادي النصر السعودي
عام
[موسيقى]